okay batches um hit your [ __ ] boys
psychobabble um let's see here let's see
here what do we have to talk about today
other than this great game we're about
to play oh sure let me just plug in the
[ __ ] controller because God knows I
need a controller because my [ __ ]
hands get weaker by the day it's what
happens when you don't eat vegetables
like you know like the other day and
what was it it was like near is like a
month ago two months ago I don't know
look at mine ears resolutions and I was
like how shet like ah like man like I
have made his resolution like these
resolution like [ __ ] suck in so I
like thought like okay like I'm not
going to be one of those people that
just give up the resolutions like I'm
going to adapt and change and what is a
believable like resolution and it just
goes to show like I was like thinking
like what what can I give up and I was
like I got it like vegetables like so
here I am like another month or so
without vegetables like it's going
strong but my hands get weaker everyday
so I gotta I gotta plug in this up just
controller and right now I'm untangling
the cables anyhow we're going to play
the walking down a new frontier I'm very
excited I heard this is pretty dope
actually um I got off just again there's
a sow going on right now you guys check
it out I'll just [ __ ] tangled I am so
[ __ ] set I have two bananas here half
let's read the iced coffee and water
okay I'm gonna [ __ ] on right now that
what is going on here
okay okay okay
I'm trying to [ __ ] checking for Dale
say okay that's word maybe it's weird
because I got this I'll get the game but
steam says there's full controller
support but I don't know that means you
can't play controller support on the
[ __ ] stuff [ __ ] I guess you can't use
the controller on gift a game did I get
the season pass I got the whole season
settings okay now let's see where the
[ __ ] and the subtitles are now it's
probably in audio/video right here right
guy here we go music now thank you
ever since I played [ __ ] morrowind I
hate music because it just lasts like
ten years controller
what the [ __ ] so can I not use Mike it's
a full controller support on Steam I
guess oh my god I guess I just [ __ ]
don't let you do it here just [ __ ]
[ __ ] well that is a major board
[ __ ] okay I guess I'm just not gonna
be able to yeah let's say here alright
first I got to use my wrists again
let's crowd like to [ __ ] is this to the
sides crowd
[ __ ] sorry I'm not a streamer
yeah supply the exchanges ok episodes
choose how to begin your story season 1
season 2 continue your story we create a
medley it shows she did community I
think oh I think shot him I can't even
remember oh I picked Jane because I read
that which I pause was the same
mmm
whoo standard Walton I can't I can't
I'll let her get remember
I think I shot her
okay [ __ ] it let's do this start episode
why it's the ties that bind I know all
about finding in bondage ha I got to put
some eyedrops in because again dry here
oh yeah Oh mommy likey oh oh daddy likey
okay okay start up a Sun why let's do
this [ __ ]
crap light on or off it's if we all
right now [ __ ] not now episode what
let's do this okay I guess it's barely
visible here
I don't like it too [ __ ] dark [ __ ]
this [ __ ] great great it adapts to the
choices you make just like parenting and
it's tailored by how you play okay great
phone calls scary signals I might be
getting a [ __ ] ton of calls and such a
hey hello okay that Graham Spanier ha
they welcome like you [ __ ]
okay you were here when dad was sick
okay I get it but you need to [ __ ] him
here when he goes huh hobby run how they
glare no I guess I mean it was banana I
guess see me David hey so so lying ray
just sayin this banana I had to leave my
cards traffic is backed up for miles so
far out the play right now do I he's
dead and I missed it no no nice I
thought you're a piece of [ __ ] you know
that one time just the one goddamn time
that you needed
be here I tried a child you man please I
[ __ ] tried bro you tried you [ __ ]
try alright as of my shitless now
everyone's here they've been here for
days and where the [ __ ] were you
we're they're all around me people who
love him all around him and she's scared
I'm seeing the panic in his eyes and he
circus guess I'm Kissin bail mr. Xavier
let me stop me hijo I'm there right
beside him holding his hand like a good
son
mm-hmm and he doesn't even see he
doesn't even see me because he's looking
for you yes I'm a bum
you guys there's a million places we'd
rather be you don't think we all had to
make sacrifices
hate me all right if it makes you feel
better I deserve it so you go ahead get
it
I intend to javi what why are you
fighting in a bench
dad's a bully
it's okay Kate your dad's just a bit of
a buoys off oh don't
well coffee's just joking knows not go
inside me home we'll be in in a minute
going it's okay inside yeah you're
supposed to [ __ ] sew it on my hands
serious [ __ ] head get the [ __ ] out of
my face you [ __ ] you want a second
jack go to Kmart okay I should call
someone pick up the body yeah I am gonna
tear this family apart that is her short
that's for sure I love you little
brother you know that right sucker
I went on [ __ ] off just suck at it you
think I was jealous you know I don't
think anything well I was for a long
time not a dadier system you've lost
more than I'll ever have but maybe
something good can come out all this
yeah she said cuz we need you here okay
yes I need me tell I'm grow up you can't
run from this match I paid nice at your
[ __ ] deck you want me around more
fine but god damn are you still one
region [ __ ] you know that you can
call me whatever you want as long as
you're here to do it to my face they had
to through a space man do it all over
his face hi
I have you got a handle handy I'm so
sorry javi I'm sorry thank you how he's
a pretty cool dude I just mom needs you
I like that he is better looking the
other guy what happened I kiss her kiss
her kiss her I want no one wants to kiss
in those games they everyone's like too
afraid to kiss
mama oh why are you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I tried I tried I'm so sorry he's gone
Miko he's gone in a better place mama
hmm pretty good story so far here's this
[ __ ] no puedo clinicnd army yes hf /
doesn't get my civvies you english plays
okay like it I put on captions for a
razor okay eggless plays like SPEA merit
am like America baby
you want some juice God top was empty
the [ __ ] you didn't have to see this cup
up anymore baby grand first sleeping no
yeah yeah it was awake okay I say must
pay for certainly some history floor
all right
thank goodness [ __ ] eating little
kissy ah yeah man
Rafa come mrs. Copely fella fetch is a
Craig window Ellie's turn off all
electrical a corn tsunami pieces to whom
do you come on
she lay in bed she's gonna get me in
what the [ __ ] he's gonna get better
Oh an ally was a late that if I could
kill them we need to go we need to get
her to the hospital she's a chick
scratch gotta yell where's your sister
Keith where the [ __ ] of the g8 dad's car
key there on the - my mom get the kids
meet at the hospital don't take the
highway
it's block we're anti-terror I'll bring
the van around
where's Maurice I don't know me huh
Mariana Mustafa Rihanna we have to go
yeah I got hurt
where is that little girl nice come on
honey we have to go it's okay
County General Hospital I know the way
a fox driving so you can't drive
oh did you get bit
I can't tell ya [ __ ] Beth today
yeah alright I guess you got a condo you
know in this game sometimes people make
feel struggle emotionally he's not mad
okay I get the job done okay
you know guys like me Stefan present-day
tell me when it reaches the campfire
I don't think I've seen this many it's
definitely growing yeah
not a great time damn it
I left my water bottle her just got
there just under four hours come on we
should keep moving while the kids are
asleep yeah that [ __ ]
Sam bolcar weird another guys I got Ben
I think I will not a danger he can't
bite you right looks like the hurt is
speeding up a little I thought it was
drifting southwest but I'm not sure
anymore
every time I think we should just bed
down somewhere and wait for it to pass I
can't shake the thought of us getting
caught in the middle of it it just keeps
coming it's slow but I must make it work
we can't move had batteries moving it
worked for us so far
as long as we stay supplied we're fine
yeah maybe you're right
mm all right it isn't so bad we'll
figure it out we always do hey I'm gonna
sneak a smoke I can't believe you found
weed
are you kidding people are probably
growing this before they realize they
needed food
tall like the catches you know make it
quick I don't want you waking the kids
relax
Marianas got headphones on and Dave is
drooling I think we're in the clear
yes smoke it take a deep deep breath
yeah but I like let me do that
you want a puff no thanks [ __ ] I have
to stay clear one of us should be sober
don't judge me
second [ __ ] look at her disgusting I
found out David had kids I told him I am
not changing Who I am around them and
when he proposed I reminded him that I'm
not exactly stepmother material that's
hard cats case in point
he was reassuring but yeah I can tell
you was worried about it I know he tried
to get me to change or at least hope
that being around the kids more would
change me you know okay with a stubborn
guy was that's like that even when we
were kids he saw the world in a certain
way and you try and make you see that
way through that's what chase had some
chance where I could get his phone I
used the talk [ __ ] about all those
mothers who'd go on about raising their
kids being the hardest thing in the
world
mm-hmm Gabe's making me start to think
they had a point
no thank you ah please I just followed
my beside me he's [ __ ] still here I'm
joking
Jesus obviously
look at statics I see this either
sometimes life decides for you that's
not the deep didn't it
mm-hmm what we saw or no it didn't look
I love these kids but I could do without
Gabe reminding me I'm not his mother
whenever he's pissed
that's gotta kick did you need your
puberty hormones kids are fellas down
and you start getting boners the whole
world starts to get dark what are you
talking about sounds delightful compared
to dealing with bloody underwear great I
need to get laid oh [ __ ] her I realized
that was an awkward transition sorry
about that
what does Wow I can pull over I wouldn't
take a minute wouldn't be worth it for
just a minute that's no gross
hey Mariana I think we are must Danis
Conqueror or something back there
I already know you guys do drugs that's
a pretty severe way of phrasing it
Mariana don't okay he's a little told me
oh oh my god you're even smoking in the
car now
Gabe is such a [ __ ] everyone roll the
windows down before you all get contact
hi we're about to make a supply stop and
I kinda just get like they just see
something and they're like a supply stop
like a [ __ ] egg people think people
living there you know like
this with the [ __ ] mystery man like
what the [ __ ]
okay bat-jets do that at Dennis in the
beginning we are one in the Sun we are
one I got it
yes second pitch Shay's it okay so
scoffs thing oh yeah [ __ ] happen to her
hey it's Nathan towel oh well my loan
Mari I'm praying I find a candy bar all
right what do we actually mean uh a
candy bar need Mariana not want pretty
much everything if it looks useful let's
use it all right well let's start with
some gasps see it how is that from that
send the kids away with supplies I meant
[ __ ] her in the truck the [ __ ]
[Music]
the sky nizami
and he's just being racist like does
anyone know like gonna [ __ ] that were
you going yeah yeah okay that's cool
have fun keep the [ __ ] deck happy few
different ends with him so you got it I
guess let me fight like that I really
hate it it's like all Gabe wants to do
with argue doesn't matter what it's
about just like it's [ __ ] that dad I
meet you a battery has been dead for a
couple of weeks
second pitch I mostly wear them to fool
you guys well when you put it that way I
wish I had a pair to unite it repair I
might just have to do that be nice to
find some dinner in a junkyard
you never know these past four years
people have been hoarding all kind of
[ __ ] in all kinds of places
oh and Mari if there's any trouble you
find one of these cars or lock yourself
in and don't come out not even once it's
quiet wait as long as you can okay yeah
good girl
gates gonna get [ __ ] e and that's for
sure that's a [ __ ] use the mouse to look
around okay I said click on things
okay talk to look at this will let me
like walk most of the dashboard is torn
out
seats are gone nice things dead like its
marriage why can I use the
oh that's gross oke
okay now I'm sorry I did that
what that [ __ ] you find anything I can't
stop thinking about that herd we get
continent and that's it peace sessile
can't charm your way out of that one
I strike facial shiny be gone in seconds
hey don't think about that we're careful
we're smart
well stay ahead of them not crumbs out
just as easily as gas there's gonna be a
last one you know a last tank of gas a
piece of food what if this place is
empty and and the next and the next
we're not gonna let that happen okay
okay I'll let it have its five minutes
good god guys got [ __ ] why can't I
[ __ ] do anything okay okay
how the [ __ ] settings controls W uh [ __ ]
why can't I move
okay it looks like every other control
works except what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what cannot [ __ ] move
so is there like a numb lager holding on
you okay hold on okay you said I could
plug in controlling
okay plug the next roll the [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] weird okay we are going into
second classes
okay now is there like a setting menu
here
what da [ __ ] [ __ ] okay let's try this
again
maybe it just got like full [ __ ] or
something you know I'm pressing the play
button so okay it looks like we're
[ __ ] that and I can I walk
why doesn't this [ __ ] work
hmm
to the applicant options again got this
[ __ ] let's play the disaster a
[ __ ] disaster
how do you change this okay
let's just say maybe for some reason
they'll work this time
alright well let's start with some gas
and move up from there
oh yeah this [ __ ] okay I like to kill
this [ __ ] again I think it was not me
actually that is [ __ ] up she at
consoles it hey where you going
come on okay that's cool
have fun Jesus it never ends with him I
hate when they fight like that I really
hate it it's like all Gabe wants to do
with argue just like a staffers that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah remember anything with your
headphones yeah but the batteries have
been dead for a couple of weeks I mostly
wear them to fool you guys yeah there's
like a chain guard yes i Chen wish I had
a pair to even borrow mine if you want
I might just have to do that be nice to
my eye so it Shane a junkyard you never
know these past four years people have
been hoarding all kind of [ __ ] in all
kinds of places
oh and Mari if there's any trouble find
one of ours that's a-ok
lock yourself in and don't come out not
even once it's quiet and wait as long as
you can okay
I got a batch good girl
okay so it turns out Wow holy [ __ ] okay
so I just press WASD and [ __ ] does not
work okay this is [ __ ] fake this is
fake and nothing worked right so then
like I'll press the [ __ ] arrow keys
that worked waste oil and then I went
back to WASD and it [ __ ] works again
so you know like it just goes a show
like nothing was ever good in this
country okay okay look you toss this
[ __ ] like it around there hey any luck
you know no [ __ ] I can you see that
email pop me a pen
oh and a pathetic pencil just something
to write with a pen why are you looking
for that there's just something I really
want I really need to do and I need a
pen for it last night I was thinking
about this stupid story my mom used to
tell me all the time before bed I used
to hate it but but then I realized I
don't remember the ending it was a goofy
ending she thought was so funny and I
thought was so dumb I want to write down
everything I can remember about
everything cuz if I forget and they're
all gone I'm kind of gone to at least a
little bit I just think that might be
kind of what focus of bodies implies you
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's it okay Mike you
know you know the drill by now get to
[ __ ] to work you [ __ ] bed in a minute
go [ __ ] yourself okay jesus [ __ ] on
grateful [ __ ] you know you can share
want that cry out yeah I think a [ __ ]
Star Line's psycho Oh Chuck I can
nothing good left someone picked it
clean pick you clean [ __ ] when she's
got words pal
just rotting bits of old rubber and
tires mm-hmm inside out and most of the
dashboard is torn out seats are gone
thanks dad my marriage okay
hold shift to walk backwards and I'm not
faster but it works this sit alene handy
for welding i'm not macho [ __ ] do you
notice every is resect in this bench
come to Papa yeah top it barely anything
I'll need to find more look at these
tires
I wish I had some ties I don't think
these tires would fit the van course not
huge ok time to give this guy a piece of
my mind
that's a [ __ ] what's going on in there
buddy I'm in a bad mood okay I wanted to
go away but he won't I just wish we
weren't always on the road I like being
with other people just run that car so
damn long people ever right it doesn't
work if you do I can't bat [ __ ] it ate
my last damn cake then we'll get sick of
other people instead of each other oh
you like that I don't know maybe just
leave me alone okay but if you want to
talk later I'm around okay
three siphon this [ __ ] yeah give me
some on that Bank bingo
this guy shirt is way too nice okay what
else can i - I love cycling look at and
that I did climb looks like there's more
to see up here
he's like shed I is my wife watching
yeah Kalon you like some not enough Gabe
hey Gabe let's go take a look over there
yeah hope you [ __ ] does stay close to
javi got it all right Gabe you're so
dumb it's just like your father
shadows was it get back now Hey look
there's one they never took two pieces
good catch
this should be interesting open look and
look at [ __ ] lot still might be gas in
the tank though alright except we're
guys like take the whole thing [ __ ] it's
locked
alright here goes nothing
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah [ __ ] it
yeah let me psych on that [ __ ] blind
lips on the ships I finish it out of it
look at all that fuel uh-uh this is
going to take a while
so over here oh that is so gross dad
it's disgusting looks like it came from
in there
Gabe stay close
nice so it
all right let's say this applies
right-click the back out at he'll now
locked we look in real quick
might be able to get in through the
hatch he's stupid [ __ ] just going to
the door I'm not going to be able to pry
this open dammit okay I guess I'm going
to the hatch anything is up just like
I'm not a [ __ ] okay go in there go in
there Gabe how goes in the dirty work
huh Gabe come check this out
not the cleanest place no muertos at
least I'd know Morrison air some sauna
just be careful
ah [ __ ] Martha's I can write time
treat this kid like [ __ ] I dispatch wow
this place is decked out I'll take your
cut at so on
it looks pretty comfortable and pretty
gross
are you kidding me
lucky for you they put enough
preservatives and this stuff to last for
centuries there's enough food in here to
keep us going for a long time
yeah looks like shut up Oh check it out
this is actual honest-to-god pudding
seriously and it's not just food there's
a mattress there's blankets someone
else's mattress someone else's blankets
we need to just take our gas and get on
the road it has a fail-safes police dogs
have a funny feeling about it
and if we're to sort of somehow surround
us okay [ __ ] now I'm officially creeped
out come on one night we bunk down you
know real meal it would be nice not to
sleep in the van for a change please the
hurt is coming if it's not here already
we should go and get ahead of it before
it's too late
the fence is reinforced we'll be fine
okay found this okay well let me just
enjoy it
we're gonna get what we came for and get
out of here great another shitty cramp
night in our shitty cramp pan hooray
okay Beulah good grateful chef food huh
thanks for that that can be up and all
how does it feel to be the bad guy this
time
it must be any sensation for you know
clearly I have a thicker skin uh you
sure the bank hey Kate can you come help
us with this what is it hey wait but you
what is that this way you can make up
for being the bad guy
Thanks grab some gas we need to head out
soon hmm someone else here what the [ __ ]
you think you're doing with our gas
don't tell me Cal gay
it's my gas now well it's not like I saw
your name on it
don't [ __ ] test me boy you ain't the
loner type I can tell I know you got
people I'm alone I'm alone honestly
people just slow me down
uh-huh alone yeah sure you are
fan out look for the others Lonnie
you're with me kill this guy
hey you [ __ ] in there I got you more
you don't want to get in shot you best
come out there careful with your hands
up
hmm go on you first you get ambushed by
her own people that shit's gonna make my
day
alright that's open it real slowly oh
god I think I want to have a trapdoor
I knew you weren't alone [ __ ] I knew it
what any yogur lonesome how come these
are all open that [ __ ] aw bet just
take what you like I ate all those yeah
me you by yourself now yeah what can I
say [ __ ] love pudding you got a real
smart mouth oh yeah buddy kissed that
mouth you [ __ ] watch what you're
saying what did you say you old [ __ ]
look I I get it alright you're starving
who the [ __ ] is it at the end of your
rope thought you hit pay dirt honest
mistake but I got this sneaky [ __ ]
feeling Wow that you're full of [ __ ]
pillow ain't gonna let it be like last
time some [ __ ] rolled on us keep an
eye on this [ __ ] I'm gonna grab some
cuffs you got it
I can't just chill okay no need to make
this any harder yeah I regret that best
you have no idea you're [ __ ] with you
I think I'm [ __ ] with somebody who's
full of [ __ ]
look man this doesn't have to go the
[ __ ] was that noise
if my dad you got hiding under there
boys my deck getta getta if you know
something you better spill it you don't
want me finding out for myself
grab the curb bar let's kill us better
guys keep a puck in here oh great call
for [ __ ] guys holy [ __ ]
now to pay for what you done here let's
say I we don't owe any human okay I'm
getting pretty good getting pretty good
okay
all right his lips are dry Oh No
lips are dry oh [ __ ]
they circumcised them this is so [ __ ]
up they're my family where are they what
did you do with my family
yes okay an [ __ ] Hector was both a
favor and pretend you're still asleep I
wouldn't start talking if I were you
you're lucky we do things a certain way
I'm already tempted to put a bullet in
your brain for what you did to Lonnie
back then we start talking I'm gonna get
angry you have to go back my family's
back there hey you got to listen to me
there's a herd coming a massive one and
yeah and that's why we're driving away
from it please just up all right you
don't want me riled up kid not another
word of god help me I'll put you to
sleep myself we still got a haul ahead
of us
and I'm not about to listen to that
oh and well nature is like going after
okay Wow
Jesus [ __ ] hey get the gun get the gun
bets would be done get the [ __ ] gun
okay
pop that mouth Oh Papa okay shoot good
that's what I'm talking about how those
go lick uncle lickin good look as tears
oh [ __ ] yeah all right that's good
just keep looking forward we got that
Clementine look I'm already having a bad
[ __ ] day here this is not what it
looks like what it looks like is you
shot an unarmed guy in the back or is
that not what I saw how's you so you
[ __ ] Clementine you're in the wrong
game okay okay now don't do anything
stupid
cuz I'll shoot a lot quicker than you
did
your keys
well wait did you do that with the tree
I was trying to stop the truck
[ __ ] Clem testing a badass yeah you
stopped it alright trees all slower than
I thought it would put your hands up
close your eyes hey come on guys I'm
talking [ __ ] now look I'm the victim
here
we're all victims oh so it's okay for
you to rob me this is payment for saving
you hey that's for my niece she loves
chocolate more than anything I promised
it to her please
keep your eyes closed and count to 100
before you go waitjust
my family I need to get back to that
firm Dania we were attacked and I don't
what I just need to know where I am
we were driving down the 522 and that's
when we found the junkyard they're still
there I need to get back to them I know
where that is you said you were driving
in our van yeah I'll take you to the
junkyard if you let me have your van
[ __ ] that [ __ ] get you there in one
piece then I Drive away that van is our
home it's all we got
that sounds like a no how about you just
give me directions like a normal person
how about I shoot you and take the van
anyway this is a better deal for you
let's go
well sometimes kind of fetch is really
necessary I don't know you I don't trust
you and I'm not taking any chances so
it's safer for both of us if you're tied
up come on you must trust me at least a
little we're here aren't we
I trust that if I don't get a van at the
end of this you'll regret it yeah sexy
name's Javier by the way people call me
Harvey Clementine
no no these were not killing me
Clementine don't thank me yet
oh shut penises with penises and wieners
will be wieners hey oh cool
I need the van this [ __ ] ain't getting
no van that's for sure you get it done
look you don't want to talk fine
but how about you give me the gun back
so I can at least defend myself for all
I know you turn around and use it on me
yeah apparently the shot gonna shoot you
shot the other guy wow you didn't tie me
up and stick me a truck my toes the hurt
caught up with us mm-hmm what does
Muertos okay
mortos what do you call him walkers what
do you call the ones that run
they're all [ __ ] walkers okay look
I'm just
that's pretty funny actually not for a
while anyway
yeah oh it shows what meaning you could
sure use a dust-up on those people
skills yeah she's kind of [ __ ] up that
[ __ ] man helped us a crash into the
air so who's that this junkyard my
brother's kids and his wife films in
China [ __ ] Isis surviving this long
not sure how you did it
just keeping everyone together like that
I want to say we help each other I
didn't do it alone my uh uh uh Kate
helped she did most of the work actually
sounds nice
having a partner it is not about you you
must have been pretty young when this
[ __ ] started I was but some people
looked out for me too
what happened to them same thing that
happens to everyone
mm-hmm we'come geriatric they become
geriatric [ __ ] well you can't stay here
there's a town at the head we can stay
there until the herd passes well your
best forgot to go where Walker food can
you do that please you want me to trust
you give me a reason give they got don't
make me regret this
come on
right that's some pretty good except I'm
stronger together what the [ __ ] get to
the gate keep going open up
hey open up oh yes it's far that
community enough I can't open the gate
till you clear them out can't risk it
Hank right here I go walk bullets will
fire alright gonna help her [ __ ] that
yeah a second trapped inside come on now
God Epping damn it Francine one of these
days those doors are going to close and
your ass will be on the other side yeah
now when that day comes trips I promise
I'll make you first
it's Clementine right you stay in a
while this time no once the walkers pass
I'm taking this guy to a junkyard off
the highway my family might be trapped
they're hiding from some very bad dudes
well [ __ ] I'm truly sorry to hear that
this herd rolled in this guy sounds like
such a circle but it's gone just as fast
so just keep your heads down and steer
clear of trouble you got me there's too
much going on outside yeah well because
uh we'll be cool we'll be cool just need
a place to ride out the herd that's all
all right I'm gonna hold you to that and
I wouldn't recommend changing your mind
if you want to hang on to all your teeth
that is that's everyone threatening have
to head on in I got [ __ ] to do well
welcome to Prescott
it's pretty cool place actually those an
old airstrip I guess the people on the
other hand they're not my favorite hmm
usually I'm in and out as quick as I can
manage it's just a pit stop
okay we're gone as soon as there's a
window I hope that window comes soon
horses any time what Oh Bobby what's
what's up family there's two welcome
Nick right already
you guys made it this long I'm sure you
know you're gonna kiss Clementine are we
gonna weird come in racine let's go I
really wonder I really have no idea I
can't McTell ages and I bought some
bullets
so I probably thought shortened season
wants you to tail which is kind of nice
jeez I haven't been in a place like this
well you know it's just like the old
days
oh my god I gotta take care of something
same time that we die that [ __ ]
what'd she get after him
I don't know why don't you make some
friends
okay I gotta be nice in this town okay I
gotta be nice in this town
I can't nothing yeah I guess I'll I
guess I'll talk to them I'll be cool
cool excuse me ah you again you got some
moves I'll give you that
hold on a minute don't I know you from
somewhere
oh I don't know maybe Garcia
Javier Garcia but what is worth I think
you got screwed on the gambling thing a
lifetime ban [ __ ] said I had a 20-year
career way I see it nothing wrong with
betting on yourself to win and that got
a lifetime ban now he just wanted to set
an example
I was the poor bastard they used to do
it on it all I know is what I read in
the papers anyway I'm Conrad this is
Francine he runs the place I just take
his money you can't look at maybe I'm
just letting you win Oh actually if
you're the gambling top games poker
five-card stud operation what do you
think should I call should have bowled
that the [ __ ] you call that bet she's
intimidated he's bluffing you got
[ __ ] written all along is that a
fact
I think I'll listen to the man call
moment of truth flip him oh my ain't
that a pretty sight
oh hell yeah nice Oh calm down both of
you thanks for the advice huh how's
about a drink on my tab oh yeah I'm
doing pretty good here Wow I just smells
like turpentine that's the weak stuff
don't turn away from me I'm talking to
you [ __ ]
it was a point in talking when I already
told you a deal is a deal and it's done
what's going on
this guy ripped me off I traded him a
crate of perfectly good batteries and he
gave me a box of bullets that won't fire
he could have gotten both of us killed
yeah yeah and who the [ __ ] are you her
bodyguard or something well I want to
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up cuz I don't scare
easy
alright damn right so you better figure
out a way to fix this and I mean real
fast
well you can't even prove those the
bullets I traded you oh wait
climb come on he knows the bullets don't
work listen to it he's not even nervous
I could have died because of his bullet
one [ __ ] boy look out yeah what the
[ __ ] I definitely make such a [ __ ] I
want to be kicked out of [ __ ] town
kill the [ __ ] hey listen it's all cool
down huh you were acting crazy
I was too we just got a little out of
hand
that's all just give me what I'm owed
Jesus you've got to get her under
control man no way they say no way to do
business
that's right punch him again he had a
deal
right hey okay all right so great well
we'll trade back I'll find some
batteries won't need battery what I need
are bullets that won't get me killed oh
oh [ __ ] oh god right now he attacked you
and he was going for his gun
I [ __ ] warned you I attacked him I
only shot because shut it you done
enough talking drop it
there's a hurt out there and you're
firing off a [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
happened here
he attacked Javy okay it was
self-defense enough from you did you
really have to shoot ah yeah it's
justified my man of course he's telling
the truth
the guy ripped the wrong reach for his
gun and would have shot me if she hadn't
stopped him see you happy now god damn
it I'm putting you two under lock and
key until I figure out what to do oh hey
what are you for real as real as it gets
now move it got some nerve coming in
with a [ __ ] of my bar Wow
mmm
ah to punch your [ __ ] lights out both
of you
but you I was a great a certified
[ __ ]
I'll even have someone come take a look
at that cut hey thanks for having my
back at the hangar
now crap babe that was cool of you
I wasn't sure there for a minute thanks
[ __ ] so yeah anyway thanks just don't
think just makes us friends or anything
of course not hello hello babe who that
kiss her kiss her on the forehead I'm
Eleanor I'm what passes for a doctor
around here
trips order over does it sometimes I
hate that I'm treating you in a cage
like you're some feral animal Kenny
laughs I just I don't stress out
seriously you said it yourself
Tripp overreacted look I'm just here to
clean up your laceration now let's see
about that wound
yeah yeah he got you good try to hold
stuff Wow
alright I suppose a pretty one through
into causing the most trouble as if good
looks equal bad behavior or something
yeah well it takes one to know one
one what one pretty troublemaker I'll
give you that one
I need to give me someone else first
thing she called a man in cold blood if
you don't mind me asking what did happen
exactly she killed a man in cold blood
arguing and then she went crazy over
nothing
nice ain't [ __ ] okay I just met with it
that's fine too
best thing Holly for you Julie town and
get back your group we were attacked
earlier this evening there were four of
us oh [ __ ] sorry I says if there's
anything you can do to help there's
something good that happened I have much
to offer you but I know a thing or two
about losing family well you really want
to help me let us out of this cage Oh
put her on the spot poet or in a spot
you done yet just about all right here's
what we're gonna do I'm driving you that
junkyard myself get you out of my hair
and no one can say I didn't do right by
no one okay in the meantime you two
could sleep right here and think about
what [ __ ] you were earlier [ __ ]
on my terms and on my timeline you got
me no no way I need to get back on the
road ASAP Javier I'm not negotiating
here yeah it doesn't seem right to wait
Bobby's people they can need a medic no
no way not putting you in that kind of
danger again they're not your clothes so
funny
look maybe there's another way we've got
a rear gate tell me the other into the
airfield we don't use it much with well
we could leave tonight let's do a
favorite let's leave together did a jump
start on reaching that junkyard
what seriously you do that for me it's
just it's the right thing to do whoo
anyway did bad Bey think about it I've
got to check on some patients but I'll
be back in an hour you know I never
would have guessed she had a dinner yeah
she's just pretty pretty she's something
thing is and maybe this sounds weird but
I still trust trip more than I trust her
no way dad she's [ __ ] gorgeous we're
leaving tonight without Leonora if it
gets us there even a minute sooner it's
worth it all right I'm in you know when
I met you I thought you'd just be
another [ __ ] like everyone else and
to think that when we first met you
nearly blew my head off
yeah guess I made the right call okay
sounds like our Emma will be a little
while maybe we should get a few winks
hell idea I'm exhausted
I'll get the lamp
the [ __ ] he gets the floor keep the
senior okay this is the rat over here
that killed the other person the [ __ ]
going on here the [ __ ] of that she just
turned it's [ __ ] up that's weird
oh she dreaming now hey what you drawing
there goofball
can I see correct
no I'm no good at this game I'll try to
guess what it is
just give me a second I'll figure it out
the [ __ ] dog breath doggie right
that's some funny [ __ ]
it looks just like me that kids like
yourself ah [ __ ] Clem AJ give it a try
clam clam I am not much of a talker are
you goofball EDA says you should be
speaking by now but don't worry about it
you'll talk when you're ready
and I decided [ __ ] that was weird
clam open up its me eateth what's wrong
from last week they're back and now
they're armed this is bad Clem there
there's a lot of them too many of them I
don't like the looks of it do you need
my help no I need you to pack whatever
you can be ready to run just in case
okay got a lot of cars and they're
seriously pissed off this is gonna get
ugly
I know it
[Music]
Hey
pack your stuff when I get back we've
got to get the hell out [ __ ]
very central come on water it made you
man our people are sick and starving it
didn't have to be this way you could
have just given us some grub some
medicine that's in this is your fault
y'all are just wanting it for your
[ __ ] self and horseshit Clem Clem
they're inside we have to go now
a lot of people walking on outside here
here was this proper oh don't give me a
J I don't want that kid lay down play
Pam okay you're okay
I see someone yes three [ __ ] shoot
off okay that I really didn't need that
and star-like I thought we were having a
good story so okay thumbs up just
appalling mad as hell by now what do you
think he'll do to you
yeah better Brad nothing I'll yell at me
a little trip annoying we sort of used
to be a thing it was for like five
minutes and I fizzled out fast so you
can do it better so you never really got
over it I gotta say I think you could do
a lot better than that meathead are you
being serious yeah guys that's the place
hello horsie okay that's time Wednesday
there's a [ __ ] sauna people show we're
gonna be [ __ ] prepared or what no and
also climatic skip my band's I got
something else to tell her gums out yeah
comes out dicks out let's do this so I
had met yesterday that's Jesus
a chef Jesus must have been hundreds of
them gates could into crisis she'd know
how to get shelter what's that
there's the pitch
Kell now I get the candy bar Mariana
tape player Mariana
Mariana are you here that [ __ ] is that
oh my god that's uh she's living in our
car I can't believe you told me where to
hide I just listened to what you said
lock yourself in and don't come out not
even once it's quiet it kept running
through my head like on a loop
she did exactly what you should have
done I always knew you were smart kid
hey is it scary at first but once the
Marco's couldn't see me anymore they
just passed by Kate and your brother
where are they we got pulled apart when
that huge bunch of muerto showed up hey
y'all that they were gonna try to make
it back to the van and that's where
we're headed let's go get your brother
back sweetie I'm just hot a [ __ ] Oh No
holy [ __ ] they shot the [ __ ] out of that
man no no sign of them they must have
seen me like this then gone someplace
else to hide
to
Mariama stay back stay back [ __ ]
wait nobody shoots he's right we fire
the truck we might hit them well it just
[ __ ] extractor okay once down my love
sounds okay I'll look to war no one
touching my girl okay
hobby you've had this hey hey it's okay
I got you you happy to see me my piano
says hate to disappoint you but there
really is a gun in my pocket nice to see
you too [ __ ] I wanted to come after
you I swear I did you don't have to snot
all over my shirt about it I thought we
were dead like never gonna see you again
dead we only had a couple bullets left I
know it must have been awful but it's
all over now
yeah I know but I was just so scared
okay if I can't [ __ ] you don't have to
be scared hey you hurt yourself mice
escaped you in the truck didn't even
notice
hey place it's not a bite Eleanor think
you can take a look
it's okay I'm a doctor I'll clean here
I'm a doctor
see better already she'd be getting back
[ __ ] plaintiff don't want to push her
Locke who's the kid with the gun that's
her daughter my name you want to share
with us clementines a friend hi there
glad I was able to help well we're very
grateful to you
really there's a town nearby it's safe I
like the sound of that
oh my god javi do they have hot water
even like lukewarm water would be okay
ah and bubble bath bubble bath the
amazing an effect whatever they've got
I'm sure it's gonna be great hey I guess
I am
search and rescue missions don't usually
end so well
alive and healthy don't it's incredible
guess I'm a lucky guy the luckiest mmm
sanitize when we get back to Prescott
you still owe me a working ride I
haven't forgotten about our deal what
they all have known what happened to
your van but still I need some way out
of here that van was the only ride I had
a lead on so maybe it's time to
renegotiate I know it's not the easiest
thing to find but cool here take that
horse
Thanks okay that happens he really does
I don't think so yeah this guy well no
the horse he is hobby we can't leave her
yeah you can oh that's okay I got all
right Gabe got that stop Cape Cod never
liked it
which a fat [ __ ] I didn't know little
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] go why did I
take her this [ __ ] death
[Laughter]
[Music]
I know hobby and there will be time for
all of that but not right now I need to
get Kate back to price level I can help
her which means you have to go first
waver your hobby we have to move before
they start shooting at you [ __ ]
killer [ __ ] kill him I'm gonna kill
all of them that's not gonna bring her
back hobby so what I'm just supposed to
let him live if you really want to help
your family you'll come with me we can't
wait any more
let's kill those wretches stay here and
be finished are you crazy
we have to go now already killed one of
you if we don't stop them they're gonna
come after your family again
Eleanor help them you stay with me
what no Bobby you have to come with us
now [ __ ]
we haven't done anything trust me javi
we have to end it now okay Prescott
we'll cover you javi
go with them I'll be fine a second
okay just keep firing until they're out
of sight okay I'm ready
good the [ __ ] is that hobby don't okay
episode went done did you stay in fight
did you stay the night only a few went
back okay go do you shoot the driver and
I shot him who's the aftermath we got
locked up the [ __ ] who brought you
we all went with a lady mistake one time
oh [ __ ]
pretty good
and the [ __ ] advertisement the middle
of [ __ ] game that I thought could pay
for this okay
well that's the end of that episode so
uh thank you thank you for watching I
hope you all enjoy it okay I hope y'all
enjoy
oh wait what's going on now okay yeah
crazy [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] well thank you
guys thank you I know our thanks for
watching thank ya